Feliz año 4721 no es el futuro es el
calendario chino que este domingo inicia
su gran fiesta una combinación de lo que
sería para occidente Acción de Gracias
Navidad y Año Nuevo al mismo tiempo
es también conocida como la puerta de
entrada a la primavera o lo que es lo
mismo el primer día del primer mes lunar
las festividades duran 15 días hasta que
llega la luna llena
esto es el doble fo nuestra palabra para
la fortuna la gente dice que la
humanidad en el mundo significa buena
suerte Feliz año del conejo y ojalá
avancéis muy lejos
China y otros países dejan el año del
tigre y entran en el del conejo excepto
Vietnam que lo hace en el del gato será
también el año del signo de agua y el
yin es decir el de la energía femenina
según la leyenda china Buda nombró los
años con los 12 animales que acudieron
para reunirse con él en este día
las personas nacidas en el año del
conejo destacan por su bondad su empatía
y su paciencia también suele aumentar su
adopción como mascota en los hogares Y
en este hotel de conejos de Hong Kong
están de celebración
creo que los conejos pueden entender lo
que dice la gente pueden sentir si
estamos siendo amables con ellos y
cuidarlos bien entonces cuando estoy con
ellos les hablo mucho les digo lo
hermosos y lindos que son
muchos conejos están en hoteles Pues el
año nuevo es también el momento de mayor
migración en el mundo más de mil
millones de personas se desplazan para
visitar a sus familiares ocasión para
darse regalos celebrar comidas
especiales y disfrutar de espectáculos
de luces